Venezuela es como Juego de Tronos. Todos queremos
saber qué va a pasar pero, a la vez, todos
sabemos que
vamos a terminar decepcionados con el final. Y precisamente, de eso vamos a hablar hoy.
Muchos nos habéis
la misma pregunta. La gran duda de este país
¿Qué puede pasar en Venezuela? Es decir,
hablamos de uno de
los mayores desastres económicos y humanitarios
de la historia moderna. En sólo 10 años
ha pasado de
exportar petróleo a exportar refugiados.
Pero todo eso ya lo sabéis. Y si no lo sabéis,
tenemos toda una
playlist en VisualPolitik dedicada a este
país.
Por supuesto, Venezuela no es el único país
que ha pasado por semejante debacle económica.
Por ejemplo,
hace poco hablábamos de Nicaragua. Durante
los años 80, Nicaragua también sufría de
hiperinflación,
escasez y pobreza extrema. Sin embargo, en
ese caso había una alternativa de gobierno
clara y era fácil
imaginar los posibles escenarios que se podían
dar.
El caso de Venezuela es una auténtica incógnita.
Pensadlo bien. El Gobierno de Maduro está
contra las
cuerdas. Prueba de ello fue el lanzamiento
del PETRO. Una criptomoneda de la que ya os
hemos hablado
aquí, en VisualPolitik, con la que Venezuela
intenta desesperadamente ganar algo de divisa
extranjera. Al
paso que van, Nicolás Maduro ni siquiera
va a poder pagar al ejército que le defiende.
¡Pero ese no es el mayor problema! El auténtico
misterio sobre Venezuela es… ¿Cuál es
la alternativa? ¿De
verdad existe alguien capaz de sustituir al
Gobierno de Maduro?
En resumen: que es prácticamente imposible
entender la situación actual de Venezuela.
Y precisamente por
eso, nos hemos ido a preguntar a todo un experto
en transiciones políticas. Y os preguntaréis
¿Os hemos
traído a un historiador? ¿A un economista?
¡Nada de eso! IVÁN PILIP fue, nada menos
que Ministro de
Finanzas de uno de los primeros gobiernos
democráticos de República Checa. Hablamos
de uno de los
responsables directos de que Chequia sea el
país que es hoy en día ¡Pero aquí no termina
la historia!
Después de tener una carrera política digna
de película, Ivan Pilip empezó su trayectoria
empresarial…
¡en Latinoamérica! Es decir, que conoce
esta región como la palma de su mano. Y hoy,
está aquí con todos
nosotros.
¡Hola Fonseca y un abrazo muy fuerte a todos
los suscriptores de VisualPolitik! Efectivamente,
es
imposible imaginar lo que puede pasar en Venezuela.
Pero hoy vamos a dibujar tres posibles escenarios.
Así que la pregunta de hoy es ¿Qué puede
pasar en Venezuela? ¿Qué posibles escenarios
nos podemos
encontrar? Hoy vamos a contestar a estas preguntas
pero antes… antes vamos a hacer un pequeño
paréntesis.
¡Porque ya sé lo que estáis pensando! Mis
queridos amigos chavistas o maduristas, que
sé que muchos
estaréis viendo este vídeo. Antes de que
os lancéis a escribir en los comentarios
que “en VisualPolitik
SÓLO se habla de Venezuela”, os sugiero
que echéis un vistazo a todos los demás
vídeos del canal. Veréis
que hemos dedicado mucho más tiempo a otros
países como Arabia Saudita o Colombia o México.
En resumen,
que en VisualPolitik cubrimos todo el mundo.
Y creo que nadie puede tacharnos de dogmáticos.
Hecha esta aclaración… ¡Vamos a ver un
poco de historia!
LA SALIDA CHECA
Quedaos con este nombre: VACLAV HAVEL. Pocas
personas han tenido tanta influencia histórica
como este
hombre. Básicamente, la República Checa
que conocemos hoy en día… la República
Checa en la que yo vivo,
es lo que es gracias a Vaclav Havel.
Lo cierto es que Chequia es todo un modelo
de transición democrática. Mientras otros
países como Rusia
todavía son pobres y extremadamente desiguales,
República Checa es una sociedad próspera,
moderna y,
sobretodo, muy igualitaria. De hecho, las
diferencias entre ricos y pobres en este país
son mucho más
suaves, incluso, que en Suecia o Noruega.
Pero ¿Cómo llegaron hasta este punto?
Pero esto no siempre fue así. Hasta el año
1989, los checos teníamos un gobierno títere
de Moscú. Bajo la
dictadura de GUSTÁV HÚSAK, cosas tan normales
como irse de vacaciones a otro país estaban
prohibidas. Si
querías alquilar una casa, necesitabas un
permiso del gobierno que podía tardar años
en llegar. Otros
países como Polonia, también estaban bajo
dominio soviético pero tenían regímenes
algo más abiertos. De
hecho, muchos checos cruzaban la frontera
con Polonia para poder conseguir libros que
estaban prohibidos
en Checoslovaquia.
Sin embargo… todo cambió a finales de los
años 80.
Aunque nunca llegamos a tener la hiperinflación
de Venezuela, si que sufrimos escasez de productos
¿Querías comprar un coche? Tenías que esperar
años hasta que la fábrica te lo mandaba.
Incluso algo tan
básico como los plátanos o las bananas era
un auténtico lujo que no se encontraba en
prácticamente
ninguna tienda. Cada día era más difícil
encontrar frutas, verduras o pescado.
A esto le tenemos que sumar el hecho de que
la Unión Soviética ya no podía seguir mandando
dinero a sus
aliados. Así que sin apoyos extranjeros y
con una economía en bancarrota, es normal
que surjan protestas
de todo tipo.
Por supuesto que la policía reprimió con
violencia las primeras manifestaciones contra
el Gobierno de
HUSÁK. Pero ¿Qué pasa cuando, de repente,
se juntan más de 250.000 personas en las
calles de Praga?
¡Habría que estar loco para disparar a 250.000
personas!
A diferencia de Nicolás Maduro, el gobierno
Checoslovaco supo entender que lo más prudente
era dejar el
poder de forma pacífica. Gracias a eso, nuestro
amigo Gustav Husák pudo marcharse a un retiro
dorado. Y a
esta revolución se la pudo llamar la “Revolución
de Terciopelo” porque no hubo derramamiento
de sangre.
Sin embargo, como os decía al principio,
la clave de este proceso fue Vaclav Havel.
Se trataba de un
escritor relativamente conocido que capitalizó
todo el descontento popular.
“La verdad y el amor deben imponerse sobre
la mentira y el odio” –Vaclav Havel
En realidad, Vaclav Havel no eran tan conocido
antes de la revolución de terciopelo. Pero
tenía todos los
elementos para hacer un gran líder… (bueno,
aquí no sé muy bien qué poner… mete algo).
La pregunta es ¿Existe un Vaclav Havel en
Venezuela? ¿Tal vez alguien desconocido hasta
ahora pero que
pueda aparecer en algún momento? No lo sabemos.
Y por eso, vamos a imaginar un escenario un
poco más
pesimista.
LA SALIDA RUMANA
¿Qué pasa cuando un dictador no abandona
el poder a tiempo? Pues nada bueno. Os lo
hemos dicho muchas
veces en VisualPolitik, liderar un gobierno
autoritario puede ser una profesión de riesgo.
Y Nicolás Ceaucescu es la mejor prueba de
ello. Se trata de uno de los dictadores más
brutales que hemos
tenido en Europa. A diferencia de Nicolás
Maduro, Ceaucescu ni siquiera se esforzaba
en preparar
elecciones amañadas. Directamente era un
sistema basado en el culto a su persona.
Pero, cuando la economía va mal, ni siquiera
el líder más autoritario de Europa es capaz
de mantener el
tipo. Al igual que el resto de países post
soviéticos, a finales de los años 80, Rumanía
estaba
prácticamente arruinada. En algunas regiones,
llegaron a verse casos de malnutrición. Sin
embargo, el 25
de diciembre del año 1989, después de dar
un discurso multitudinario, los ciudadanos
pasaron de los
aplausos a los abucheos en cuestión de segundos.
Días más tarde, el Kim Jong-Un rumano era
ejecutado por
sus opositores.
Sin embargo, en este caso NO fue una revolución
en contra del régimen. Ni siquiera lo mataron
los grupos
anticomunistas. Ceaucescu murió a manos de
sus propios compañeros de partido. Fue un
caso de golpe de
estado interno. Donde una facción más moderada
del Partido Comunista Rumano se hizo con las
riendas del
Gobierno Rumano.
En el caso de Venezuela, podría ser una facción
del gobierno o del propio ejército. Por supuesto,
no
tendría que terminar con la ejecución de
nadie. Simplemente, hablaríamos de que Nicolás
Maduro se vería
obligado a abandonar el poder y marcharse
a su casa… o a una mansión de lujo en cualquier
país que le
acepte. Al igual que ocurrió en Rumanía,
hablaríamos de un cambio totalmente cosmético.
Caras muy
parecidas en el gobierno pero unas políticas
algo más moderada.
Está claro que la Rumanía de hoy en día
no es un ejemplo de nada. Pero, al menos,
es un país estable, con
cierto movimiento económico y donde, al menos,
ya no hay pobreza extrema.
Y antes de continuar quiero hacer un paréntesis
y aquí si que voy a ser tajante. En Ningún
momento
estamos deseándole el mal ni a Nicolás maduro
ni a ninguno de los miembros de su gobierno.
Nos estamos
limitando a analizar la situación actual
de Venezuela comparándola con precedentes
históricos.
Absolutamente nada más. No estamos diciendo
ni que este escenario fuera el más deseable
ni muchísimo
menos que sea nuestra recomendación o que
sea lo que nosotros deseamos ¿A quedado claro?
Vale. Ahora si
queréis podemos continuar.
Hasta el momento, no se sabe de ninguna facción
interna dentro del gobierno de Maduro. Y por
eso, todavía
nos queda un último escenario… Un escenario
digno de película pero… ¡Todo es posible
en Venezuela!
UN PAÍS EN VENTA, LA SALIDA CHINA
¿Recordáis que os decía que China es el
único aliado que le queda a Venezuela? Lo
cierto es que China le
ha prestado más de 60.000 millones de dólares
al Gobierno de Nicolás Maduro. Muchos de
estos préstamos
son lo que se podríamos llamar “PETRO CRÉDITOS”.
Es decir, China le da un dinero a Venezuela
y Venezuela,
en lugar de devolverlo en divisa contante
y sonante, lo devuelve en una cantidad equivalente
en petróleo.
Tiene sentido ¿Verdad? Si hay algo que le
sobra a Venezuela es el zumo de dinosaurio.
Ya sabéis que es el
país con las mayores reservas de crudo del
mundo. Así que, en principio, suena como
un buen trato para
Maduro.
¿El problema? Que como también sabéis,
la empresa estatal que se encarga de sacar
el zumo de dinosaurio
Venezolano, PDVSA, es auténticamente caótica.
El barril de crudo venezolano es el más caro
de extraer del
mundo. Mucho más que el canadiense o el noruego.
Eso explica que PDVSA sea incapaz de extraer
su propio
petróleo. Para que os hagáis una idea, la
producción de esta empresa a duras penas
llega al 43% de su
capacidad. Y cada vez va a menos.
Muchos inversores chinos ya están perdiendo
la paciencia. Pensad que no sólo estamos
hablando del
gobierno de Xi Jimping sino también de muchas
empresas privadas que habían comprado bonos
del Estado
Venezolano o que tenían inversiones en el
sector del petróleo. Y eso explica noticias
como esta.
La empresa China SINOPEC demanda a Venezuela
como muestra de unas relaciones que se están
deshilachando
Pero la pregunta… la auténtica pregunta
es… ¿Qué podría pasar si Venezuela no
pudiera devolver las deudas
que tiene contraídas con el Gobierno de China?
No olvidéis que tanto el ejército como la
policía de
Nicolás Madura está armada con el dinero
que llega de China. Es decir, que China podría
paralizar el
Gobierno de Maduro en cualquier momento. Eso
significa que tienen poder suficiente como
para incautar
muchas de las propiedades que PDVSA tiene
en territorio Venezolano. Es decir, que hablamos
de la
auténtica joya de la corona.
¿Pero de cuánto dinero hablamos? Pues bien,
a día de hoy, los activos de PDVSA tienen
un valor de 231.000
millones de dólares. Y Venezuela le debe
a Xi Jimping más de 60.000 millones de dólares.
En otras
palabras, que Beijing podría quedarse con
la cuarta parte de las propiedades de la empresa
más grande de
Venezuela. Prácticamente, la única. Para
que os hagáis una idea, el zumo de dinosaurio
supone el 97% de
las exportaciones de Venezuela. En otras palabras,
que quedarse con PDVSA es, prácticamente,
un sinónimo
de quedarse con Venezuela misma.
Esta nueva dirección de PDVSA podría hacer
los ajustes necesarios para que la empresa
pueda volver a
funcionar. En principio, esto sería una buena
noticia para la economía Venezolana, que
volvería a
producir algo que poder exportar. Pero ataría
de pies y manos al gobierno de Nicolás Maduro.
En otras
palabras, sería como vender todo un país
a los inversores chinos.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Es esto posible? ¿Hay
algún signo que nos lleve a pensar que esto
va a ser una
realidad? Pues fijaos en esta noticia, publicada
hace unas pocas semanas en XINHUA news. XINHUA
NEWS,
como ya os habréis imaginado por el nombre,
es un portal de noticias chino, completamente
adepto al
régimen de Xi JImping. Atentos a la noticia.
Maduro crea la primera zona económica especial
basada en el PETRO
SI lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik,
ya sabéis que eso de las “zonas económicas
especiales” es
algo así como la marca de la bestia. Cada
vez que China decide hacer negocios importantes
con un país en
crecimiento, lo primero que vemos es que crea
una zona económica especial. Un espacio que
tiene unas
leyes especiales, basadas en la legislación
China, con impuestos bajos y facilidades para
montar
empresas. Pero en este caso, podrían ir un
paso más allá. No sólo hablamos de invertir
en un país, o de
hacer negocios. Hablamos de comprar la espina
dorsal de la Revolución Bolivariana. Maduro
sin PDVSA es
como un rapero sin quincalla. Así que, si
controlas toda la economía de un país, incluido
el modo en el
que se financia un gobierno… ¿No podríamos
decir que has comprado el país entero? Pues…
algo así podría
terminar pasando en Venezuela. Ya os digo
que es una teoría totalmente insólita. Nunca
se ha visto nada
parecido en la historia. Pero… todo es posible
en este país.
Y ahora turno para ti ¿Cuál de estos tres
escenarios te parece más plausible? ¿O tal
vez crees que
veremos una mezcla de los tres? Podéis dejarme
la respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por mi parte, ha sido un placer estar un
ratito con todos vosotros. Si queréis, podemos
seguir en
contacto a través de twitter. Me encontraréis
en @Ivan_Pilip
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos al canal para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en
el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.